développements en ukraine maintenant les
mouvements des troupes russes dans le
sud du pays en crimée se multiplient sur
la scène internationale ça sème
l'inquiétude on y reviendra dans
quelques minutes
avec notre chef de bureau à interros
emmanuelle latraverse mais sur le
terrain c'est très clair l'armée russe
tu dit maintenant le pas comme nous le
dit jean françois bélanger qui est sur
place autour de cette base ukrainienne
d'ingénieurs de marine de la visite pas
vraiment bienvenu des soldats russes
arrivé en matinée qui en bloquent
l'entrée me plais blanc et des
représentants du gouvernement
autoproclamé de crime est venu
parlementer ou plutôt négocier une
reddition pour les soldats qui veulent
quitter repartir en ukraine le peuvent
dit il ce qui veux rester ici et servir
la crimée où la russie le peuvent aussi
autant d'options inacceptable aux yeux
du commandant de la base
monseigneur je réponds aux ordres du
commandement de la marine d'ukraine dit
il nous ne quitterons cette base que si
kiev nous en donne l'ordre
bien évidemment ce face à face entre
soldats de pays frère est venu jeter
tout un émoi dans cette petite
communauté où tout le monde ici vivaient
ensemble en paix du moins jusqu'à il ya
quelques jours un rouge ni logement peut
pas vous qui bande d'herbe l'attention
ministre a clairement montée d'un cran
entre ses voisins qui vient de découvrir
aussi idéologique et s'est pas masqué
wannian déjà yougov médiate callas
habite juste à côté de la base militaire
et n'ai vraiment pas rassuré par la
tournure des événements maintenant j'ai
nommé ni commune et sûrs d'eux les
personnes auparavant de s'intéresser aux
origines ethniques de ses voisins dit
elle
tatar ukrainiens russes iraniens des
gens ce qui se passe actuellement est
très dangereux dit elle je ne veux pas
que tout ça se termine comme en
yougoslavie cheminée vous recopie
rosberg à deux coins de rue
une autre base militaire arbore encore
fièrement les couleurs de l'ukraine
son commandant et c'est de garder la
tête froide
au milieu du chaos libellées raturées
jusqu'aux genoux il faut éviter à tout
prix que des gens meurent bêtement du
terrain nu et pour cela il a un message
à l'intention des politiciens de chaque
côté c'est un crossover au juge burgaud
s'asseoir autour de nathalie verser un
bon verre de thé prendre des cadeaux et
se parler pour trouver ensemble une
issue pacifique style si simple et
pourtant visiblement si compliqué ici
jean françois bélanger radio canada
bharti sarrail crimée